Alaska's weird science plot
gone wrong
Sarah Palin is back in the news
after emerging from her
bear trap to inform America
that she's as much
as scientist as Bill Nye.
(imitating Palin):
Don't ya know?
-The guy who's got "science"
in part of his name. -(laughter)
So the Internet naturally
flipped out. But you know what?
Let's give her
the benefit of the doubt
and compare their résumés.
Bill Nye spent
over 30 years working
in the field of science
with companies
like Boeing and NASA.
Sarah Palin spent over 30 years
working in the fields of Alaska
hunting for big foots.
-(laughter) -So, let's pretend
for a second maybe she knows
what she's talking about.
Comedians, what are some
Sarah Palin science facts?
Steve Agee.
Uh, the front crack is pink,
and the back crack is brown.
(laughter)
Suck it, Neil deGrasse Tyson.
-(laughter, applause
and cheering) -HARDWICK: Right?
Um, interesting.
Yeah, I think the, uh...
the science checks out on that.
-Joints. Uh, Doug.
-Yeah.
The Jungle Book is the greatest
documentary of the year.
-(laughter) -HARDWICK:
Joints to Doug Benson.
(applause and cheering)
Tyler.
(imitating Palin):
The reason the sky is blue
is because
God is sad about the gays.
-HARDWICK: All right joints,
joints. -(laughter)